can we watch the video one more time I
gotta remember something like what's
next in my time at TC I put myself
through a number of ridiculous cooking
and baking trials okay
god I'm so over this but it dawned on me
why should I have all the fun so I'm
challenging to my friend Scotty L and
julissa to tackle one of my recipes the
giant chocolate souffle how would you
guys rate your skills in the kitchen
well I can cook bacon hmm I have burned
some cookies in my day show me how I
just put it in the oven and that's it
leave it in there okay great Oaxaca
bacon challenge accepted so for this
challenge are you just gonna watch the
video and then you're gonna compete to
see who can recreate the dish the best
with absolutely no instruction beyond
that and up ends I'll be judging to see
who did the best job so what's the video
once and that's it because I'm not a
total jerk I'm not throwing you guys
some lifeline during the challenge you
can either peek at the video or you can
FaceTime me and ask me any question you
want
oh okay all right okay well I'll leave
you guys to it
and the best of luck he's gonna need it
are you ready let's do it
Wow Rami King is Rami King did you stir
that mother can we curse too late you
know cuz that is the job I'm not gonna
tell you this is easy no no no this is
ridiculous
Shh you're distracting me they put in
the chocolate back in the bowl why is it
growing like that
I'm not like that any what happen let
the games begin
what are you doing god you're so
annoying that you hate it I want to know
what you don't want no that's messed up
yeah you gotta put the sugar in there
mm-hmm
I can't wait to see everything they're
about to do God we should have had a
divider I'm gonna take a break just let
you go for it I'm heating this up right
now and then why don't put some milk in
there no I know what I'm doing
you just kind of look confident oh right
I'm gonna put that in there why are you
giving me for your thing I just don't
remember how much you gotta put it in
here
[Music]
so we stirring it because we got a
chocolate into the Melton now
[Music]
we're like this is not thickening did I
miss something
I gotta stop copying her she's ruining
my stuff and I'm gonna watch that video
one more time I'm using my life line so
you're really gonna turn it away from me
and I know let me watch so and I get a
life in a tree now I'm gonna show you
okay let's watch oh wait a minute
grrrrrr she still got a life line I'm
not using their lifeline right now but
you cheated I see the rest of it cuz she
took over you can put the chocolate in
it
see I helped you see I already know that
why are you feel 30 because it's good to
continue stirring when you don't know
what you're throwing I'm just waiting on
that plastic put a plastic right here
something is terribly wrong
I'm gonna do it the way I'd do it hers
already having a little texture this is
just water you sure like my using my
plane what is they gonna do now exactly
we don't know what we mess it up now and
then in the future it'll be too late I
feel like it's already too late that's
why you quiet
what are you doing I'm securing my bowl
never gonna copy long um where's the
refrigerator I thought we were friends
yes I'm not supposed to do this but it's
watery it's a new way you're gonna want
to put these back on the heat and make
sure they get second up but you put the
plastic on like this right he's right
about the classic yeah in your face I
didn't do it because look at this yeah
that's all right this is dumb okay I'm
gonna leave how about it good luck it's
never happened
that's fine
she's watching the video then I'm not
I'm supporting God yell we were on a
break I didn't look at it I have
receipts of what he was trying to look
up get up why because you told me not to
that's not why he didn't know how to
spell souffle we corrected our mistake I
finally got in with putting the little
rap on top on because I know what I'm
talking about what's the next step
I already did the next step I put the
egg whites in here the other powders I
was around the egg whites I don't know
what it was and I stir it up I use the
machine cuz I was stirring it up at the
same time as I was stirring the
chocolate booyah because that's how you
say time my friends now what we're gonna
do is keep stirring this thing up make
it nice and smooth and then we're gonna
mix this thing in there am i right yes
and then you're gonna make it feel all
soft and fluffy put everything in here
and then afterwards in the oven for 30
minutes and we're gonna rise up that's
right
[Music]
Wow look at that look at that I like it
like that
any Baker knows that before you put it
in the oven you have to preheat the oven
right also goes for sex a bear at 350
degrees 375 I wish I could read lips
girl I'm gonna put the whole thing in
there because ain't nobody got time for
anything else see how creamy that looks
that's I supposed to look people kind of
not getting fluffy cuz you show no love
that's what happens people I do not
remember seeing her do any of that
and my big minds at 375 because maybe
that's a part of the video ain't see I'm
acting confident but I'm really not
confident at all baking is hard this is
so easy why do you think Bubba I'm just
taking my time
yeah look at the fluff you don't want to
lose the fluff I didn't lose the flock
they're all using this alright I think
mines is good like that little of water
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's kind of getting my head but I'm not
stupid [ __ ] is gonna come out delicious
look at that I don't like the way looked
the thumb is for later no wait it's
before you put it in i'm not saying how
much time I'm gonna put mine in for it
because he's gonna go and copy me
just like he switched his temperature on
my big minds at 375 so I'm gonna refrain
from speaking any more on what I'm doing
mine's is just baking and I'm ready
mine's is bacon too and when it's ready
it's gonna be dope it's not really good
I think it looks good oh this is the
easiest part and this is the best part
because you can cover any of the
imperfections okay yeah he needs to
cover it
I hope shoulda saw what it look like
okay this is what you actually want your
souffle to be like a little bit wet
inside it's supposed to be light and
airy when you eat it I don't know what
souffle supposed a sex but that is good
I mean it's souffle it always tastes
good I'm gonna have to be critical here
though tell them that is mushy to me is
bushy I'm getting a grainy texture on my
tongue after I eat it and also when you
first look at it there wasn't any rise
up out of the souffle dish so that's
telling me that you probably like really
whipped the batter when you were
supposed to really lightly fold it how
did you do the folding process I never
had a whole division that's what's gonna
happen it you're not gonna get like a
light and airy souffle and it's not
gonna rise up but I mean it's chocolate
if they rise up it was like in the
middle and I couldn't eat it we're gonna
try let me try this one nah I think like
some weird aftertaste like protein yours
are so on the gooey air side which is
good you don't want to over bake it but
it is a little walk a lot let's walk a
lobby hmm not good
I like mine's better you can tell I
might have more love I heard it was hate
I will say though your top look nicer
didn't have the rise like a souffle
should have but it had a flat top with a
little bit of scoop in the center and
that means it's not like overdone Gaudio
had some weird bubbly surface Jason
tasted better they're both kind of wrong
based on the elements that I'm looking
for out of a souffle they're pretty
close
but I can't even finish it it's a
definition but it doesn't have a protein
aftertaste guardian just take it fair
and square that you lost you also use
the hand mixer when you were supposed to
vote only for my clothes you also bought
him for 350 when it specifically said
379 I put it to some fun choose my
lifeline so both the show by one and
guess one I didn't use it like mad at my
book she bought my book if I couldn't
tell you so ha ha
you know what at least we did great this
is delicious and it was fun to do
imagine if we had the video there how
different a water came out yeah
souffle is one of the hardest things you
can make so you guys should both be very
proud of yourselves it was actually
really hard I was saying it was easy but
I was like good job got you good job you
two you Lisa
[Music]